1月1日
皆さん
新年あけましておめでとうございます
はじめしゃちょーですというわけで
2023年になりましたとりあえず天気が
いいので外行ってこようかなとりあえず
今日天気がいいのでちょっと外行ってき
ますお家の外行ってきます
オレンジめっちゃ天気いいな今日1月1日
なのに
[音楽]
何もしてねえな
帰ろう
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
逃走中ですありがとうございます今年
初めて会った人が
[音楽]
知らないおじさんだった改めまして
新年あけましておめでとうございます
はじめしゃちょーです
[音楽]
去年もたくさんの人に応援していただいて
無事に2,022年走り切ることができ
ました皆様ありがとうございました
ちょっと前にも動画にあげた通りあの
決して満足のいく1年ではなかったです
けども
すごいその分いろんなことを勉強したし
経験したし
体験させていただいて初めてちょっと今後
どうするべきなのか何がしたいのかとかを
はっきりとあの明確に表すことができた
2022年でした19
やめないです今のところはな今のところは
読めませんけど今のところやめませんよ
言ったことと違ったらやめるかもしれませ
んけどね本当にあの素晴らしい事務所なん
で今後ともよろしくお願いしますただね
本当に何回色々と考えさせられた去年だっ
たななんで俺はYouTubeやってん
だろうとかをなんか何を大事にしたいん
だろうとかいろんなことを考えたのよ去年
もびっくりするぐらい自分でもすごい悩ん
だし割と苦しかったし自分の
優先順位がめちゃくちゃになってて自分が
本当にやりたかった
自分のチャンネルの動画を作るとこに
すごい時間をかけるということが
去年ほぼできなくてすごいなんか自分に
足りないものとか必要なものとか自分がし
たいことやりたいことすべきこと
周りの人に求めていることいろいろ分かっ
た1年でした
今年の初め社長は
[音楽]
尖ってます今年のはじめしゃちょーは尖っ
てますよなんか意識してないと全然わかん
ないと思うんですけども実は
僕ははじめしゃちょーここ23年3年
ぐらいかなあの1回もまともな炎上して
おりません
YouTuberの鏡ね鏡ではあるんです
けども鏡ではあるんですけどもそれ
すなわちどういうことかというとあの
安牌
安全な方を取りに行ってるというかいや
炎上することが正しいとは思わないですよ
炎上することが正しいとは思わないけど
個人的にはやっぱりそのーなんか
ぶっ飛んだことをすると絶対賛否両論が
起きると思うんですよ
仕方ないそれはだって初めて見ることだし
やっていいことなのか悪いことかもわかん
ないでしょ
初めてのことって新しいことってだから
あの
俺ちょっと
炎上しなくて寂しかったっていうとなんか
炎上しそうだからそういうことは言わない
んですけども実はここ数年全く炎上してい
ない超クリーン系YouTuberはじめ
しゃちょーです
それをそれを殺すことは払拭しようとして
おります私はじめしゃちょーええそれよ俺
は払拭しようとしています
いや
演奏はしたくありません炎上したくはない
けど
俺やっぱ
賢いのかな
炎上しないで怒っと思ったら本当に炎上し
ないようにできるんですよ正直言い
ましょう炎上しないでおこうと思えば炎上
しないでも行けますがそれだと
つまらん
めっちゃ炎上したい人みたいに見えてるな
今炎上したくないですけどももう何が言い
たいかというと今年は今年2023年の
初めの
テーマは
わがまま
わがままにつきますこれだけ
悪いけど俺は今年
誰一人俺以外はじめしゃちょー自分以外の
人間のために自分の融点の下げることは
ないです
HIKAKINさん以外俺が優先なさる
ことないのですいませんかなり自分勝手に
行かせていただきますごめん周りの人には
迷惑かけると思う後輩とか事務所にもご
迷惑をおかけすると思います
YouTuber仲間のみんなもごめん
どんなことがあっても自分を最優先に考え
て自分のしたいことを確実にするそんな超
わがままな1年にしたいと思ってます
ごめんだから俺今年性格悪いわ性格悪い
です自分のためになるならばもう何でもし
ます逆に今までが優しすぎた非常に余っ
たり性格をしてて今年は何が何でも1番の
優先はこのはじめしゃどのチャンネル
メインチャンネルここに動画を出すことだ
とはっきりと
明言させていただきますなのではじめしゃ
ちょーの視聴者さんをお待たせしました
今年は
動画を頑張る1年にします
ひょっとしたら俺今年尖るんでなんか自分
で分かるんですよまこれ言うとなんか叩か
れそうだなとかこの発言は炎上しそうだ
なっていうのを結構分かるんすけどもう
思ったことをなるべく言うように
自分に素直に思ったように動くそんな一年
に始め社長したいと思っているわけで
ございますはいそんな1年にするそして皆
さん忘れているかもしれませんが僕毎年
縛り何か一つ縛りプレイみたいなやつ決め
てるんですよあの毎年お菓子を1年禁止と
かコメ禁止とか色々禁止をしてきたんです
けれども去年が
禁止なしっていうルールでしたたまには何
も禁止なしで生活しようみたいな感じで
禁止なんですけども
えー今年の禁止も
決まっております
決まっておりますが何を禁止しているかは
ちょっと今
言いません
ごめんな
ごめんなちょっと今言えなくて言えないん
ですけどもあの今年の年末にはきっと
言えると思うのでぜひ楽しみにしてて
くださいあの
相当厳しいものになると思う厳しいものに
なるというかマジかとマジかって言われる
ような気がしますけどもちょっと頑張って
みますごめんね言えなくてあの
気づいたらコメント欄で言ってね何かを
禁止してますので今年1年間バシッと言い
たいんですけどちょっとまだわからなくて
できるかどうか2023年の最後に一緒に
確認しましょうというわけで今年は今年は
もうなんか頑張るとかじゃないんすよ去年
から頑張ってましたただ頑張れのその力の
入れどころがこのチャンネルにな
るっていうことで引き続き頑張るんです
けどももうほんと自分にしたいこと自分の
したいことをもう
自由にやらせていただきますまず第一に俺
が楽しいこと
それだけもう原点に戻って
俺が楽しければ全てよしという方向性で
やっていきたいと思いますだからごめんね
俺の悪い部分というか性格の悪い部分とか
人としての悪さとかわがままなところとか
結構出ちゃうかもしれないんですけども
あのぜひそこも楽しんでいただいて等身大
の始め社長を今年はお見せしたいと思い
ます
ちなみに皆の思ってるほど俺キラキラした
人間じゃないからねまあ
楽しみにしててくれよじゃあ
宝くじ開けよう
[音楽]